tout dans la nature semble vouloir
devenir haut d'une goutte d'eau à une
planète de vos yeux jusqu'aux étoiles la
sphère semble être la forme parfaite
pourtant quand on regarde notre système
solaire où notre galaxie
c'est pas le cas c'est l'un des joueurs
vraiment la voie lactée ses cent mille
années-lumière de long pour 500
années-lumière d'épaisseur c'est deux
fois plus fin qu'une pizza napolitaine
et la question c'est qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour qu'un soleil héros donne un
système solaire plat vous allez voir les
lois de la physique derrière tout ça
sont aussi fascinante qu'étrange et si
notre galaxie avec des boules voici à
quoi ressemble et notre système solaire
il ya 4,5 milliards d'années à l'époque
ce n'était qu'un morceau d'un immense
nuage de gaz et de poussières une des
bulls primordial
puis une catastrophe a eu lieu la
collision entre notre galaxie avec l'une
de ses voisines
ça a provoqué une immense onde de choc
qui a amorcé le morcellement de notre
nuage sous l'effet de la gravité la
matière s'agglutinent elle forme des
grumeaux qui finissent par s'effondrer
en leur centre pour produire ce qui
allait devenir le soleil encore
aujourd'hui 99 8 % de ce nuage se trouve
en ce seul point
tout le reste les planètes c'est les 0 8
% restants des miettes
ce processus de formation des systèmes
solaires est assez proche de celui des
galaxies sauf que le nuage était
constitué de soleil des centaines de
milliards de soleils étonnamment ici la
matière ne s'est pas concentré au centre
le trou noir central ne représente que 0
0 0 0 3% de la masse galactique
comment expliquer une telle différence
avec le système solaire et comment ça a
pu finir par donner la même forme une
partie de la réponse pourrait se trouver
dans la cage galactique qui nous entoure
la matière noire 16% de la galaxie c'est
du gaz et des étoiles tout le reste
c'est de la matière noire elle en tourne
aux astres dans un cocon protecteur
c'est un peu comme une glu invisible
la théorie veut que du coup sans elle
les étoiles s'éloigne de notre galaxie
pourtant il existe quand même des
galaxies ce sens matière noire et elle
s'en porte très bien
le problème c'est que la matière noire
n'explique pas du tout la forme plate
mais si la matière noire nous étaient
visibles elle prendrait comme toute
chose une forme sphérique parce que tout
tend vers la sphère et ce pour une
raison très simple une de ses propriétés
extraordinaires sur une sphère tous les
points à sa surface sont à égale
distance du centre sur une planète
cubique au sommet des coins vous êtes
très éloignés du centre et fatalement
l'action de la gravité le ferait
s'écrouler pour reformer une sphère
cette propriété aurait eu une
conséquence tragique pour nous si elle
s'appliquait totalement à l'échelle de
la galaxie elle aurait tout simplement
été aspiré compressés au centre du trou
noir
pour finir en une sorte d'immense
coizard même à proximité nous n'aurions
pas pu survivre
non si notre galaxie et notre système
solaire sont plats c'est grâce à une
autre force
pourquoi notre galaxie et telle plate
dans la voie lactée notre soleil tourne
à 828 mille kilomètres heure autour du
centre de la galaxie pourquoi cette
vitesse et qu'est ce qui nous a donné le
mouvement primordial comme on l'a dit
galaxy et système solaire où commencer
par un nuage à l'intérieur de celui ci
tout est en mouvement les trajectoire
chaotique des collisions constante
or le chaos dans la nature il a tendance
à vouloir s'ordonner prenez des
métronomes désynchronisée les vibrations
qu'ils vont produire sur la table vont
peu à peu influencé l'éguille jusqu'à ce
qu'elle se synchronise pareil pour le
courant électrique
au lieu de se diffuser partout où il va
se donner avec de belles branches les
lignes de lynch den berg
il en va de même dans l'espace les
collisions vont d'elle-même vouloir
s'éviter et quelle meilleure forme pour
ça que de réduire l'espace de contact de
passer d'une serre à une crêpe pas
besoin d'aller très loin
il suffit d'observer les anneaux de
saturne des milliards de débris qui avec
le temps ont fini par former un anneau
là où tous les éléments ont synchronisé
leurs rotations
cette rotation c'est une des clés
fondamentales dans l'univers il n'y a
pas tant de différences entre une
planète et un enfant sur un manège
ils sont tous les deux soumis à la force
centrifuge
c'est cette pseudo force qu'utilisent
les cuisiniers pour faire une pizza au
début tout ne pas en forme de boule puis
en la faisant tourner en appliquant une
force sur le côté la boule de pâte
s'étale jusqu'à donner un disque tout
plat la revoilà notre pizza galactique
un mouvement qui est d'ailleurs en
parfait équilibre avec la gravité cette
planète veut être éjecté mais le soleil
lui dit pop up tu restes ici toi
au contraire si elle s'approche trop sa
rotation va commencer à augmenter et
donc la force centrifuge aussi on
appelle ça la conservation du moment
angulaire
tout est parfaitement à sa place alors
voilà on a notre explication tout
devient plat à cause de la rotation
induite par l' ordonnance du ko mais ce
n'est malheureusement pas si simple
pourquoi les formes parfaites de
l'univers de son île bull ni un disque
dans cette vidéo on vous a beaucoup
parlé de formes parfaites dans l'univers
en réalité la perfection on observe
jamais rien que d'autres planètes ce
n'est pas une serre elle est légèrement
aplatie sur l'épaule
à cause de sa rotation et comètes et
astéroïdes ne sont ni ronde ni plate
mais plus souvent patatoïde avec parfois
des formes encore plus bizarre
même moi moi un astéroïde plat ce n'est
pas les lois de la physique ils ont
aplati ce sont vraisemblablement de
grosses collision un pur hasard de la
nature notre galaxie aussi est loin
d'être plate
elle est légèrement incurvé sur les
bords ou l' influence gravitationnelle
du centre est moins prononcée aussi
disons le c'est plus une spirale qu'un
disque ya une spirale organisé autour de
quatre bras principaux tournoyant comme
une pieuvre site une forme très
particulière quand même la raison de ce
phénomène est assez facile à comprendre
regardez un tourbillon dans l'eau ou un
cyclone ce sont des spirales
logarithmique dans le cas des galaxies
c'est un peu différent les mathématiques
ne prédisent pas cette forme de pieuvre
il faut ajouter une donnée
supplémentaire les ondes de densité en
gros la matière ne tournant pas la même
vitesse partout dans la spirale est la
tendance à créer des embouteillages ce
qui entraîne la formation de ces
gigantesque amas de matière
c'est plutôt pratique puisque sa force
les nuages à se regrouper et créer des
soleils c'est beau hein
profitez-en bien parce que la forme qu'a
notre galaxie aujourd'hui
n'est que temporaire par le passé elle a
été plusieurs fois des formes et en
avalant au moins cinq autres galaxies et
dans le futur en fusionnant avec
andromède
ces deux titans risque de provoquer des
ondes gravitationnelles surpuissante qui
transformeront a jamais l'espace qui
nous entoure après je vous rassure en ce
temps deux milliards d'années
il ya le temps ces événements sont
l'occasion pour les galaxy de prendre
des formes un peu spécial dans l'univers
il ya toutes sortes comme les galaxies
vampire tellement massive qu'elle avale
toutes les autres des galaxies méduses
dont les gaz sont si chaud qui la
suivent en filaments des galaxies
pétales de fleurs provoquée par l'ondé
de choc d'une collision précédente
les galaxies à nos percutée par une
autre galaxie à très grande vitesse lui
volant une grande partie de sa matière
certaines comme 55,19 perdent carrément
leur trou noir et deviennent des anneaux
de feu et enfin des galaxies mourante
qui n'ont plus de mouvements rotatifs et
qui perdent peu à peu leur forme
finalement les galaxies plate et spirale
dont on a parlé ne représente que deux
tiers des galaxies de l'univers c'est
pas une règle absolue non dans la nature
tout ne tend pas devenir une boule une
pizza c'est un état un parfait équilibre
temporaire qui se forment sous l'effet
des forces de gravité de rotation et de
collision le tout contrôlé par la
matière noire
notre voie lactée ne gardera pas
toujours sa forme sublime comme toute
chose un jour elle disparaîtra si ce
genre de vidéos vous plaît pensez à nous
soutenir
abonnez-vous à la chaîne mettez un petit
pouce bleus de l'amour c'était ni oxis
et ma tarte avec à la rédaction oui sli
merci de nous avoir suivis allez les
amis ciao
[Musique]